good afternoon ladies and gentlemen I
was just going to hand over the floor to
you commissioner and then we applied for
two short questions all right
commissioner thank you Dan we know each
other too well so um good afternoon
everyone good afternoon Chancellor
um we know that you're under time
pressure so I'm going to be very brief
if I can persuade my iPad to cooperate
which is Will
um as you see we've just signed uh
that's the purpose of the Chancellor's
visit we've signed a memorandum
understanding between the European Union
and the United Kingdom and this deals
with the regulatory cooperation in
financial services I think it's fair to
say we've turned a page in our
relationship based on the Windsor
framework and indeed thanks to the
leadership of President Van Der Lyon and
vice president marushefkovic and prime
minister Rishi sunak this has allowed us
to move forward in the spiritual
partnership based on trust cooperation
and delivering benefits for people on
both sides and this mou we've just
signed is one example of the benefits of
partnership so in concrete terms it sets
out a forum that will allow our services
DG fisma on our side here at the EU
level and hm treasury on the UK case
side to meet on a regular basis as we do
with other partners including the United
States and we expect the first meeting
of the Forum to take place this awesome
and this structured cooperation will let
both sides talk to each other about
things like regulatory changes on both
sides International developments or
risks to financial markets because we
share a commitment to financial
stability a market integrity and
protecting consumers and investors and
while the UK is no longer in the EU or
indeed in the single Market we still
share many of the same issues and
challenges like fighting Financial crime
supporting sustainable finance and
enabling digital Finance so it's really
positive that we've had this structured
cooperation in place and I now hand over
to the chancellor thank you very much
commissioner McGinnis we are absolutely
delighted on the UK side to be able to
sign this memorandum of understanding we
also see it as a an important Turning
Point
um we have a shared interest in Global
Financial stability the UK is the
biggest Financial Services sector in
Europe and we have a particular
responsibility to work closely with the
EU to make sure that both sides are
doing what it takes to make sure that we
have that stability that is so important
when there are so many difficult events
going on around the world we see this
very much as not the end of a process
but the beginning we think the enhanced
dialogue will make possible will make a
real and tangible difference on both
sides and we also totally agree with you
um
question McGinnis that we have shared
objectives and cooperation is absolutely
essential so I think it's an important
day for all of us
thank you very much Chancellor and
commissioner as I said every time for
one or two short questions Sam
I'm flaming from the financial times
could I ask about another
um potential What was seen as a
potential benefit from Windsor which was
Horizon uh it seems that talks on
Horizon have have stalled I wonder if
that's correct what's going wrong with
the talks um because the science
community on both sides seem to think
that uh every day that's lost with no
deal is a lot a day lost to the science
community
I'm happy to go first um I wouldn't
describe them as stalled I think that
they are becoming more crunchy as we
start to work out precisely what terms
for participation in Horizon would
be fair to UK taxpayers and work for the
UK but I think both sides recognize that
it is a successful and very important
program
and the optimal outcome will be to find
a way where participation can work for
the UK I think it was very clear at the
press conference with prime minister
sunak and president vondreline when the
Windsor framework was agreed she
immediately spoke of Horizon and I think
both sides know that there are benefits
to have a shared area around science and
Innovation I like the word crunchy I'm
not involved in the detailed discussions
but I think the objective is a shared
one and certainly I would encourage more
crunching so that we get a result
okay Maria
thank you so much uh Mr Hunt at the IMF
you told me by the end of the year we
will beat forecasts the UK economies
navigate and now a difficult moment do
you still believe he will do better than
expected and I wonder this collaboration
is it beneficial for both in terms of
growth GDP and more work than you can do
together
thank you um let me go first
um I think um at the IMF we said that we
thought we would prove the IMF forecasts
wrong and the managing director very
generously said we had proof them wrong
because she came to London and upgraded
the UK growth forecast by from memory
0.7 so the UK economy is proving more
resilient than many people predicted but
inflation is too high and that is the
most important challenge we face and we
will do what it takes to tackle that and
we'll do it working in collaboration
with our European friends and allies I
mean this is my second meeting with the
chancellor I was in London recently
where we also had very good conversation
I mean we know in this room where the
world is so the United Kingdom is no
longer in the European Union but we need
it after seven years since the
referendum to fix our relationship and I
think today is an important part of that
process but you ask an important point
or are there other areas where we
cooperate
look what we're doing around sanctions
against Russia
we share common problems so Financial
instability in one area of the world has
impacts elsewhere so not only is it
important that we find a way as we've
done with the memorandum to have a
structured dialogue and work together we
do that with other partners globally
because we want to make sure that the
financial system remains stable The
Challenge and I won't speak for the UK
economy for Europe has been covered and
this illegal Invasion and yet I would
also use the word resilience of our
economy despite that including labor
pressures across member states what
today I think is important and I think
this will be the last question so my
closing remarks would be that some of
you know the memorandum has been around
for a little while but we kept it
protected so that the ink did not fade
so it's very strongly written this
allows us now to move forward for our
services to be in touch and to establish
this biannual structured dialogue where
we will be able to tease out many of
these issues that impact on our
financial system Chancellor
thank you um I just think we are having
very good discussions and uh crunchy
discussions can be friendly discussions
and uh that's what will happen
let's do a final handshake now if the
chance to present something with a
crunchy I will worry let's do it
thank you very much good afternoon thank
you thank you everybody
[Music]